[Music]
it's like when the air hit my tongue it
hurt
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by lizzo she's a
three-time grammy award-winning
singer-songwriter and i wouldn't be
surprised if she adds a few more of
those trophies to the mantle with her
latest project it's called special no
features no skips and it's available now
lizzo welcome to the show come on talk
that [ __ ] for me thank you happy to be
here well you deserve it before we get
started how are you around spicy food
so i'm pretty good i had an addiction to
hot cheetos and i survived the one chip
challenge so i think this is gonna be um
a piece of [ __ ] cake
so try me
it smell good
it smells really good it's fragrant
there's notes there's floral notes
all right let's get it
[Music]
[ __ ] all right let's get it
and then you'll start at the other side
here or here there there there [ __ ] you
almost had me inside at the moment no no
i was i was on it i was honest
yeah be careful [ __ ] okay this is the
first one yep the classic garlic fries
damn
you almost had me [ __ ] up
i was watching
that's good
so i want to start by congratulating you
on the release of special a 12-track
opus that you've described as your sonic
dream and in a recent interview with
vulture your producer ricky reed tells
this story about how you laid down the
gauntlet in the studio telling him i
want to lead the conversation regarding
drums can you un-package that
[Laughter]
we it was a conversation that we had
where like
you know fast music wasn't really
a thing right now it's not popular
it's like slower drums are more popular
like the
like the trappier drums and i was like
what happened to the
i'm so excited what happened to those
like fast like fun 80s drums so yeah we
wanted to speed up drums in the 2020s
like every decade there's a new musical
sound and i'm like why not make a
statement you know and then the opening
bars they can be kind of tricky but
they're important because they can set
the tone for the album was it
immediately obvious to you that special
should open with hi [ __ ] and
then you talking about making smoothies
hi [ __ ] did you miss me
no
i actually wanted to start the album
with like a moodier like i had this like
beautiful song i wrote
and i'm singing it's a ballad on violins
no drums like super dark and then i was
gonna be like this is the intro you know
and then ha [ __ ] happens and
then julie greenwald from atlantic
records was like no no this is the
beginning of the [ __ ] album and i sat
with it for a while and i was like duh
like every little album starts with like
a fanfare in your face like i'm crying
cuz i you know and so this is like a
classic lizzle album intro right in your
[ __ ] face that wing was good i
ate the whole thing i saw that are you
ready to move on here to the next one
adobo loco island wing sauce
oh it's island yeah yeah what island is
it from a little tropical vibe over here
hawaii
[Music]
i might be like the greatest of all time
because this is nothing you know there's
something in the air right now it feels
historic you know something legendary
yeah legendary legendre legendary
how's that
so you experienced a whirlwind
breakthrough in 2019 but i know the road
to get there was a winding and
exhausting one working through music
scenes in minneapolis and houston and
for a while even living in your dented
subaru what would you say is unique or
distinguishable about minneapolis's
underground hip-hop scene because it had
kind of a mythical place for me growing
up listening to like atmosphere wow
brother ali and idea and abilities
wow
holy [ __ ] yep like
um
there is an incredible like
rap and local scene there um that i
didn't even know about like because you
know i'm from houston yeah and i
remember when i was like wondering like
should i move to minneapolis i don't
know because there was a producer that
was like come live with me
i went to south by southwest that year
which i went every year
and that particular year every band i
went to see for every show i went to i
was like where y'all from they're like
minneapolis minneapolis i was like how
is every minneapolis band here like
saturating south by southwest and i was
like this is a sign to go and i went and
like there's so many incredible rock and
music clubs there so many incredible
bands rappers performers singers you
could sell out every venue there with
local acts alone in one night
i had like the chalice girl party and i
dropped lizzle bangers there and they
supported me so [ __ ] much in
minneapolis pound for pound what would
you say is the throwback underground
lizzo rap song that had the hardest bars
regular
you're so wild how do you know about
that oops
tell these people i used to wrap um
i mean let's we got to give it to
batches and cookies i was rapping so
fast
remember that gooey gooey you took it
said do we you i need to with two of
these for my baby bowie you we floating
like buoys you got a nice pair like some
boobies are you high off that doobie
doobie with your mr machine scooby
feeling bad when you should be bp don't
make nothing stop it keep going
still god i still got it are you ready
to move on here to this next wing you're
doing so good yeah this is like
literally
i'm sleeping right now oh i'm asleep
[Music]
this one good too i got a leopard on the
front
so you often hear hollywood actors talk
about formal acting training but not so
much with musicians how if at all do you
think that studying classical music
theory shaped or informed your approach
to making hits now
for me um i just had to breathe yeah yes
you had to breathe backwards on that one
um
open the window yeah i know
[Laughter]
being classically trained is incredible
because i feel like i can speak
a language you know i make pop music but
i like to think that i make really
musical interesting pop music that you
know i think a lot about the composition
you know i want my music to sound good
even when you mute my vocals you know
what i'm talking about and you hear the
track and you'll be like damn this is
like a rich piece of music that
you know [ __ ]
john williams couldn't conduct with the
[ __ ] boss john williams yeah jurassic
park w jurassic park park jaw star wars
shout out alleged legendary harry potter
all of it's
understanding the time signature you're
in harmony and dissonance and rhythm and
cadence i think it is important and then
i i read a blog post from a music theory
teacher the thesis of it was this
rumors flirts with phrygian mode i hope
i'm saying that right rumors flirts with
fijian mode using a great deal of
chromaticism i don't know what that
means but confirm or deny
confirm um the song was is difficult
because it goes between major or minor
and um so it's a half step up and down
so um
[Music]
that was a major and a minor change in
one song and it and it goes back pretty
quickly
yeah it's pretty intricate musical [ __ ]
right there
shout out to whoever the pooh is at i'm
gonna i'll find the byline but but you
co-sign
shut up shut the [ __ ] up shout the [ __ ]
out
[Music]
mm-hmm
hitting
it good
what dj khaled did like two of these
yeah we got to three so we we just made
it past the khaled mark over here i
understand why he stopped it
i did it you get it that's good yeah so
far hidden so far those calientes i'm
like that there we go there we go
from an artist perspective how do you
decide on a lead single
about damn time was the last song i
wrote for the album i was turning in my
masters in march i wrote about damn time
in february and i was like this one
about this one because the hook wasn't
done versus wasn't in a minute i'm anita
it wasn't there yet so i was like um
and when i finished it i was like oh
[ __ ] this is something
now that i've been so down and under
pressure i'm way too fine to be
distressed
it's like
hello we needed that right then when i
dropped that [ __ ] so
i'm so bad at picking singles for myself
because i think everything i do is
incredible i really do
i'm just going to breathe
because like breathing for some odd
reasons getting weird it's getting a
little weird it gets dangerous over here
it might be the yeti and the yeti you
know it's holding me in
give me a second
[Music]
there's a chili that's coming back to
you right you know why it's probably
you're having a pavlovian response
that's bringing you back to the one
child
yes because there's a common thread in
the pepper
that carolina reaper
i didn't think about that till just now
but yeah
this isn't bad
it's just i got scared for a second but
now i'm good oh
crushing it's just crushing these videos
i'm using your [ __ ] knives i
know are you eating the chicken i'm
right with you i'm right with you i'm
right with you
okay i'm right with you
and so i'm lumpy okay no i got it
[Laughter]
all right
so i'm intrigued by this quote of yours
i don't look to celebrities for style
anymore because i've learned the chain
of command with that in mind what we
want to do is show you some iconic looks
from the past we'll pull them up over
here on the monitor
i'm just curious sort of how you reflect
on these things looking back okay so the
first one damn
i'm such a bad [ __ ]
what went into masterminding the candy
bar look from the 2020 brit awards and
then shout out to the clutch i'm
american chocolate i look like a snack
there's a chocolate drop on my head too
and the makeup is chocolate and my nails
are chocolate bars
see those are the details that's what
i'm looking for right here yeah the
purse say 100
that [ __ ]
we good
oh versace
two times at the grammys multiple
versace dresses in that great i had to
do it twice it was my first time going
to the [ __ ] grammy so we wanted
to be like super old hollywood classic
wow you chose some really beautiful
photos i just did an interview the other
day and they showed some of the first
pictures ever taken of me of all time
and i was wearing flannels and duck
shoes out of my [ __ ] closet
um so thank you for this um yeah i
wanted to be classic and um i i was i
look beautiful
so this next one is the collard and
ghost here from hot and saucy i just
wanna shout out this looks like a black
female owned business it is i want to
say shout out to my sisters
keep running this [ __ ] start your
business today because we on hot ones
and let me tell you girl
i'm loving the blowout
it's twist out whatever yo you know yeah
i'm uh um i'm a high porosity girl so i
don't know what your process all right
let's get it yeah let's hope you enjoy
let's hope you enjoy the sauce after all
that
because if it's nasty i'm gonna be like
[Music]
it tastes like collard greens
as advertised
this i can get into we gonna be all
right
we gonna be all right
i'm not mad at this there we go
do you find that as your star power
grows does it become easier or more
challenging to stay ahead of the
zeitgeist it's growing
[Music]
we're good
you thought i was going to fall no dogs
go far
they didn't want me to win
when i was young
right
i used to have these ideas and i would
write songs and stuff and i would think
of things and then like months and or
like a year later i would hear that song
that i had the idea for on the radio or
i would see things and i'd be like damn
like i felt very like
i got the same ideas that the people who
are putting out the ideas got and i've
always had confidence in that so
even now as the static gets bigger and
you know i become so synonymous with the
cultural zeitgeist i think that my
confidence that i've had ever since i
was little and my vision is has stayed
true so i really do trust my instinct
it's the one thing i can trust in this
crazy [ __ ] world
are we doing any more wide shots
uh maybe can i take my shoes off go
ahead go for it cause for some i just i
can't really take
just go i can't take it no more make
yourself at home over here
who the [ __ ] is tearful we're about to
find out
how far forward are we on the spice
level
so as you can see we're approaching the
finish line over here we are in six
figure scoville numbers right here can
you tell the [ __ ] at home uh [ __ ]
at home
[ __ ] at home we are climbing we are
climbing right now i thought i wasn't
gonna win you thought i was gonna
rock a gibraltar no i'm saying
rock at a halter top
well speaking of speaking of and the
chain the yeti chain
what tools in your life as an
entertainer do you think have served you
best as the ceo of a shapewear brand
like yeti
i'm a finisher oh i'm gonna show it
don't be a little [ __ ] i'm going with
you i'm going with this shot
i'm looking for the lizzo ride over here
no reaction
[Laughter]
um
ce ho is what i like to call myself like
i'm very hands-on with my career
hands-on with everything that i do like
there's a specific kind of bra and i'm
wearing it right now that i wanted to
make just for me it's a long line bra
that pushes up your titties and holds
the sides and i can have them in
different colors so i don't just have to
wear them underneath my shirt this was a
very selfish dream endeavor that you
know i selfishly brought to the world
you know to make clothes for me it's
selfish when you're creating it and
selfless when you're putting it out
how are you doing so far i feel great i
feel a good tale
you know what i'm saying that was cute
right
look at me
look at me yeah look at me i'm the
captain now yeah you are oh there we go
i'm the [ __ ] captain now
there we go
i know
i know
oh
no i can't go
now i can't go to that cause i just
dipped a bomb in there jesus jesus
there's nowhere to run jesus jesus jesus
so i know that you've been on the hunt
for the best plantain sandwich in the
entire world where are we at on that
journey have you found the one yet
yeah it's okay yeah
oh my gosh
[ __ ]
go ahead tear the place up i feel like
my ancestors was talking to me for a
second
they said stop
you know
my titty hurt
my titty
hold on yeah yeah take your time
[ __ ]
let's hit he said stop
all right hold on yep
you did this before
[ __ ] you did that one
i'm sorry i'm going to answer the
question yeah yeah yeah
plantain sandwich
[Music]
it's like when the air hit my tongue it
hurt
hold on
take your time take your time
my hair can't wait
i had a really good one that black
freaking vegan
really going to new york
you know
i feel like it was seasoned
it was juicy
had vegan cheese on it
no yeah where did it stop
so the worst is over when does it stop
though this when does this one stop 15
20 minutes from now
this will all just be a memory it'll all
be a memory
careful around your eyes and stuff i'm
not gonna touch my eyes
[ __ ]
damn that was [ __ ] up i know no i'm
serious
what the [ __ ]
you know what you did i do i do you know
what and this is always a show i took
two bites
and that was on you though
so i feel like you're my brother this is
spiderman you're my brother yeah
and you're my sister liza oh
oh
no no
i don't know
yeah i know
grinding
all right
i can eat this one whoa
i'm just trying to keep up over here
keep up with me i'm trying i'm trying
all right what else we got
what are the intangible qualities that
distinguish a good backup dancer from a
great backup dancer
i think that a great dancer
the great backup dancer
has an awareness
go back and match your dance
they learn the moves
great backup dancer
has an awareness of the space around
them
a great backup dancer can pick some [ __ ]
up somebody throw something on stage
crate back there pick it up
still hit the steps you all saying yeah
a great backup dancer can support me
energetically
on stage
i think a great backup dancer
that's all i got
i don't got anything else
one bite was fine right yep yep here it
is what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ]
is that we're coming in we've got oat
milk ice cream okay ice cream
we got a vegan peanut butter to the
rescue
[Laughter]
[Music]
you held up
you are that [ __ ] you are really that
[ __ ]
last nap last dab gordon ramsay he cool
he's a cool guy he's the [ __ ] best
all right that's all i want to know
all right all right
what a dream we did it
album out yeti out watch out for the big
girls emmy nominated six times six times
i'm with you
top of the mountain still this was
this was the highest on my list of goals
[Music]
it's like the absence of this yeah yeah
yeah all right comes back
yes yep oh this is hot
everything is
we're going in
going in
following the ice cream
and lizzo we've made it we've conquered
the wings of death today and if we've
learned anything along the way
wings of life from church choir to
destiny's child to classic flute your
music predilections your influences they
run the gamut so to close things out i
want to do kind of a quick association
game with you where i toss out a musical
act and you just give me the first
thought or two that comes to mind when
you think about them okay
james galloway
the man with the golden flute
marijuana death squads
[Music]
you like that one you like that one you
took me back
i'm in death squads i'm in deaf squads
um fun
little flip
oh my god
freestyle king
coldplay oh
coldplay incredible band
i did it that's it we said that there
was history there was history in the
room today and it is time to put the
crown
on queen lizzo's head
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the tale
this is the hottest [ __ ] sauce i've
ever had in my entire [ __ ] life
i just want to say thank you to all
y'all who believes in me watch out for
the big girls we six time emmy nominated
ghost stream special
and go get some yeti yeti.com [ __ ]
[Applause]
i feel like the queen right now
i couldn't believe how hard it was to
focus on the questions yeah yeah yeah
yeah i was like i was like
i wanted to answer so bad oh [ __ ] the
[ __ ] hot
oh wow
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's video
the season 18 sauces they're here and
you know what that means dom box me
so is the big box the season 18 hot ones
box is now available at heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands
and all of the season 18 sauces
delivered straight to your door and one
convenient box don't forget to be
careful around the eyes